a sonic boom
startled the DC area on Sunday
it turned out to be F-16 fighter jets
headed to assess a possible threat over
the nation's capital
the FAA says that it was a Cessna model
560 like the one you see here it was
headed from a municipal airport in
Tennessee to Long Island MacArthur
Airport in New York when it reverse
course later flying through restricted
airspace over Washington
according to a NORAD statement the
military jets responded to intercept the
plane around 3 20 p.m
an even deployed flares to draw
attention but the pilot was unresponsive
it wasn't until nearly 8 PM that search
teams reached the crash site on foot
police said no survivors were found